we have an incredible lot of evidence
that most of the mass the universe is in
the form of some kind of elementary
particle that's different that it's yet
to be detected and we call this stuff
dark matter
now the leading idea for what their
matter is is it's something that doesn't
interact first of all of light that's
why it's called dark matter it does
interact very strongly with normal stuff
like us and it also doesn't interact
with itself very much it's basically a
particle that it doesn't do a lot other
than tug on other things gravitationally
but there are new ideas out there and
one of them is that there's an entire
Dark Sector that this huge chunk of the
universe that made of dark matter
actually has its own set of interactions
going on just like in our own sector the
periodic table of elements and atoms and
all the complexities that's going on
with a normal manner maybe that kind of
thing is going on in the dark matter as
well
and so while I the research is I'm
trying to figure out what the universe
would look like if the dark matter atoms
kind of interactions and specifically
we're trying to predict what when the
cores of galaxies look like if we
actually had this different kind of dark
matter compared to this more standard
dark
all minutes the dark matter that I
studied we call itself interactive dark
matter and one of the cool things we've
discovered is that if you put this kind
of dark matter in and stain kind of
simulations that we've done other types
of dark matter you tend to get things
actually to match the data better than
you do
with this sort of normal type that
doesn't interact so it very well may be
that there's this whole interesting car
except they're going on the way we're
going to find the first hints of it is
by studying the way galaxies behave and
the speeds with which stars are whirling
around each others now in the course of
galaxies